menschen sind verunsichert haben angst
um ihre zukunft um ihren job und
millionen arbeitnehmer innen befinden
sich in kurzarbeit ganze branchen sorgen
sich um ihre existenz und bei mir ist
gleich einer der mächtigsten
wirtschaftsbosse deutschland siemens
chef joe kaeser mit ihm möchte ich über
all das reden er ist ein mann der gerne
mal aneckt mehr als 40 jahre ist er im
konzern seit sieben jahren
vorstandsvorsitzender von siemens
joe kaeser chef von rund 386.000
mitarbeitern weltweit
anfang nächsten jahres gibt der
63-jährige den vorsitz ab seine letzte
grosse tat der lang geplante umbau des
konzerns die abspaltung der energie
sparte siemens energy
dort wird er im nächsten jahr
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender joe kaeser ein
global player
[Musik]
und auch politisch mischt er sich ein
öffentlich bezeichnet er trump als das
gesicht von rassismus und ausgrenzung
und kritisiert dass die fdp-politikerin
weidl mit ihrem nationalismus dem
ansehen unseres landes in der welt
schade zur festnahme der cbot kapitänin
carola rakete twitterte er
menschen die leben retten sollten nicht
eingesperrt werden
auch vor siemens macht die korona krise
nicht halt rund 8800 der mitarbeiter in
deutschland sind aktuell in kurzarbeit
im zweiten quartal ging der gewinn um
mehr als 60 prozent zurück insgesamt hat
die korona krise die deutsche wirtschaft
hart getroffen
lufthansa am boden der automarkt
zeitweise lahmgelegt im april dem
höhepunkt der krise ist der deutsche
export um mehr als 30 prozent
eingebrochen
die zahl der arbeitslosen hat sich im
vergleich zum vorjahr um rund 637 1000
erhöht auf der straße wächst die
unsicherheit über die zukunft
wir haben angst ich habe angst wir haben
angst was kommt auf uns zu
uns betrifft zeit jetzt ist
wahrscheinlich sind es aktuell dass wir
arbeitslos werden was für mich früher
selbstverständlich war ist jetzt zur
zeit doch nicht so selbstverständlich
war ich kenne durchaus einige die eben
schon pleite gegangen sind besonders
klein unternehmer und selbstständige
kämpfen mit den folgen der krise
normalerweise knallt und brust zu dieser
jahreszeit im moment haben wir gar
nichts zu tun die mitarbeiter sind zu
hause das ist ein trauriger zustand und
der im moment auch ohne perspektive
erscheint wenn man so ein bisschen in
die zukunft druckt dann macht man sich
echt sorgen weil es wird jetzt nicht mit
drei vier oder fünf monaten getan dass
es länger dauert es länger dauern als
wir uns überhaupt vorstellen
die existenz bedroht angst vor der
zukunft all diese sorgen dürften auch
ihm bekannt sein er trägt immerhin die
verantwortung für über 380.000
mitarbeiter weltweit joe kaeser herzlich
willkommen schon angst haben sie in den
letzten monaten oder auch aktuell angst
dass alles zusammenbricht inklusive
wirtschaft nein das habe ich nicht
natürlich sind wir besorgt weil wir
heute noch gar nicht genau wissen wie
diese pandemie sicher nach vorne
entwickeln wird besonderem stoffe habe
besondere medikamente haben für
diejenigen die von der krankheit schwer
betroffen sind aber menschen die gerade
glauben dass hier verantwortung
übernehmen können für 388.000
kolleginnen und kollegen werde weiter
davon keine angst haben
sie müssen sich mit perspektiven kommen
die den menschen zeigen dass es auch
eine zeit nach corona gibt sogar also
noch 8000 mehr als ist gerade genannt
es ist ja schön wenn man ein bisschen
über sie liest dann erfährt man dass ihr
vater fabrikarbeiter war auch sie haben
sich hochgearbeitet immer schon bei
siemens gewesen beeinflusst sie das
spiel jetzt zum beispiel wenn sie auf
die krise schauen wenn sie die nöte
ihrer mitarbeiter sehen wenn sie dann
auch zum beispiel sagen keine entlassung
wir gehen erst mal auf kurzarbeit also
ihr eigener weg beeinflusst der sie bei
rationalen entscheidung der beeindruckt
mich sehr weil ich glaube dass man
rational entscheidungen nicht treffen
kann ohne dass man den menschen zuhört
und versucht sie sich hinein zu
versetzen
diejenigen die vielleicht am 25 des
monats gucken müssen waren dran waren
der lohn
dann aufs konto kommt und das hat mir
auch überhaupt die ganzen jahre viel
gegeben dass ich mit einem menschen in
der fabrik genauso sprechen kann über
hertha bsc vielleicht hier in oder union
berlin
hier in im hüttenwerk oder mit größen
der welt wenn es darum geht wie
volkswirtschaftliche themen zu
interessieren sind
das ist mir ganz wichtig und das zweite
wenn man so lange bei dem unternehmen
ist 40 jahre das sind es doppelt so viel
wie nicht in meinem leben dann kriegt
man auch da habe ich eine andere
beziehung zu dem unternehmen es geht
dann nicht mehr nur materielle dinge es
geht darum wie wird denn die nächste
generation dieses unternehmens dafür
sorgen dass es weitergeht
ganz interessant bei ihnen sie sehen ja
auch wenn wir jetzt auf das unternehmen
auch zu sprechen kommen corona
tatsächlich als chance sie überlegen
gerade für rund 140000 mitarbeiter
möglicherweise home office zu etablieren
aber bleiben wir noch mal bei dem er
sich gerade auch gesagt habe bei der
kurzarbeit siemens hat für 8800
mitarbeiter dieses geld nun beantragt
wenn ein konzern im vergangenen
geschäftsjahr 5,6 milliarden gewinn
macht warum brauchen sie hilfe vom staat
erst einmal muss er ja sagen dass wir
die 5,6 milliarden in der konstellation
wenn die umsätze massiv zurückgehen und
die wirtschaft einbricht dabei weiterhin
errechnen werden zweitens ist es so dass
kurzarbeit und alte maßnahmen die wir
gemeinsam machen ja nicht eine hilfe vom
staat ist sondern das ist im grunde eine
sozialpartnerschaft die unternehmen in
deutschland ganz besonders haben die
möglichkeit über die sozialpartnerschaft
sie sehr flexibel zu verhalten
da geht es um kurzarbeitergeld da geht
es darum dass wir sagen bei uns geht
jetzt so lange wie diese
flexibilisierung haben verlässt hier
keiner das haus wir werden
vorübergehende
beschäftigungsschwankungen gemeinsam auf
aber das unternehmen profitiert doch
davon von der öffentlichen hand dass das
sehe ich nicht so weil die option wäre
dass wir uns ähnlich verhalten müssten
im internationalen wettbewerbe wie das
zum beispiel jetzt sind in den usa der
fall ist und das kann doch gar nicht
angehen dass 49 millionen menschen auf
die straße setzte es möglichkeiten gibt
gemeinsam und verzichte gemeinsam und
verzichtet zu machen in der
sozialpartnerschaft
der staat hilft der in teilen über
kurzarbeitergeld wie zum beispiel
bei den unteren lohngruppen die
differenz zwischen dem kurzarbeitergeld
und dem dem nettoverdienst den die
menschen feierten fangen wir auf und
geben dass in den unteren lohngruppen
das ist eine sozialpartnerschaft jeder
muss geben wie karim sie also wenn ich
da einmal nachfragen darf würden sie
dann auch geben ich weiß dass sie sagen
also jetzt zum beispiel auf gehälter und
boni zu verzichten das ergibt keinen
sinn weil das am ende natürlich wieder
in das unternehmen einfließt und es
vergrößert im grunde den gewinn des
unternehmens aber sie könnten ja zb als
vorstand oder auch im aufsichtsrat sagen
hey als zeichen als solidarisches
zeichen auch in die gesellschaft hinein
wir sind ein vorzeigeunternehmen wir
wollen viele dinge richtig machen wir
können was zurückgeben
ich spende mein gehalt oder wir
verzichten oder will verzicht sondern
wir spenden die boni das wäre ja eine
möglichkeit das ist eine sehr gute
möglichkeit mit dem boni wird halt nicht
sehr viel werden aus guten gründen weil
ja die gewinnerin oder in der engen ein
klar tanz sind aber ich freue mich dass
sie diese diskussion aufbringen weil es
gab viele kolleginnen und kollegen im
management deshalb mag ich verzichte auf
eine boni na ja das ist ja dann wirklich
so die jetzt sowieso nicht gegeben also
das war so die ich etwas zu vermitteln
was nicht real ist
einige sagten ich verzichte auf meinen
20 prozent von einem grundgehalt das ist
ein guter anfang es ist mehr ein zeichen
der solidarität als dass man hier
wirklich einen großen wirtschaftlichen
einschnitt hat nur es ist tatsächlich so
wie sie sagten wenn ich auf gehalt
verzichtet sinken die kosten des
unternehmens und damit steigt eingelegte
gewinnen für aktionäre und im
schlimmsten fall für hedgefonds das kann
es doch eigentlich wirklich nicht sein
insoweit hatten wir uns entschlossen im
vorstand und im management dass wir
spenden für gemeinnützige einrichtung
und ich hatte selbst aus meinen eigenen
mitteln eine million euro gespendet für
einrichtungen und zwecke die die
pandemie auch bekämpfen helfen und das
geht dann eben nicht als geringere
kosten fürs unternehmen damit höheren
gewinn sollten das geht dann wirklich
dahin
wo wir soziale zwecke auch erfüllen
können und dann menschen helfen können
das wird den zuschauern die zuschauerin
freuen gerade besonders die die sagen
mit den großen unternehmen
die meisten hören schon wirecard
rumspringen haben wir ein problem weil
es gibt natürlich bestechungen es gibt
korruption es gibt steuerhinterziehung
und vieles vieles mehr was wir in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten bei bei
unternehmen auch immer wieder gesehen
haben wie viel unmoralische angebote
herr keser gab es in den 40 jahren oder
vor allen dingen auch in den letzten
jahren seitdem sie chefs sind an sie
also ich habe da nicht mitgezählt aber
jedes einzelne moralische angebot wer
eines zu viel
sie wissen vielleicht dass wir 2006 2007
mit dem größten verbandes bekannt
gewordenen bei bestechungsskandal der
der nachkriegsgeschichte zu tun hatten
und also da hat man wirklich die
abgründe gesehen das war wirklich eine
unglaubliche entwicklung die sich
ergeben hat als wir haben es wirklich
auf harten weg gelernt aber mittlerweile
kann ich ihnen sage was unsere menschen
jetzt keine großen scheiben mehr
brauchen sondern sie haben wirklich
gelernt als werte basiertes verhalten
und die die es nicht gelernt haben und
die gibt es leider immer noch auch bei
uns im unternehmen
die finden wir selber raus unsere
compliance abteilung deckt immer wieder
fälle auf die man einfach nicht mehr
verstehen kann weil wir bei uns im
unternehmen nicht mehr versteht dass wir
eben keine bestätigung machen dann kann
man echt nicht mehr helfen und aber es
gibt wirklich leute zb die wird ein
anderer wirtschafts boss oder
regierungschef oder was auch immer die
dann mit einem geldkoffer kommen wie
stellt man sich das aber was also diese
dass es einmal so 007 dinge sind die
gibt es jetzt nicht mehr dass da einer
mit geldkoffer kommt es gibt mir die
subtilen dinge wo es dann heißt neuer
taktik zum großen auftrag aber der wäre
so eine firma demonstriert dabei helfen
den auftrag dann auch abzuwickeln
systemintegration ist ein zauberwort
und wenn man das schon hört dann sollte
man eigentlich gleich die türe wieder
von innen nach außen schließen
sie haben eine tür aufgemacht auch
ungewöhnlich für jemanden in ihrer
position nämlich die twitter tür also
die tür zu den sozialen medien wir haben
es auch gerade im film noch mal gesehen
sie lehnen sich da auch gerne mal aus
dem fenster auch unter anderem gegen die
so genannte alternative für deutschland
also für die afg haben sie wenn sie das
tun mit ihren klaren ansagen keine
befürchtungen dass sie arbeitnehmer
innen geschäftspartner und ähnliches vor
den kopf stoßen verprellen geschäfte
verlieren
das ist natürlich eine sehr sehr
schwierig hier angelegenheit weil
tatsächlich das für sie sagen ja real
existiert es gibt es gibt kunden die
bestimmte gesinnungen haben es gibt
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter die
bestimmte vorlieben für bestimmte
parteien haben und es gibt natürlich die
geschäftlichen interessen das heißt als
das abwägen zwischen werten persönlichen
menschlichen werten und interessen dass
das ist nicht digital
das wird auch immer an der luft bleiben
das ist nicht schwarz oder weiß gut oder
schlecht da muss man am ende des tages
selbst bezieht ins reine
und ich möchte es noch mal sagen weil
sie ja diese sogenannte mir gefällt es
gut diese so genannte alternative für
deutschland angesprochen haben die afg
seine partei die in deutschland in einer
demokratie zugelassen ist das sollte man
auch respektieren
und wenn man das nicht gut findet dann
muss man sich anderweitig damit befassen
aber sie ist zugelassen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob es jemals wählen würde
aber es ist zugelassen was ich damals
adressiert hatte war eine eine
hasserfüllte ausgrenzende beleidigende
rede eines auf dem i geht unter dem
bundesadler im bundestag
und ich kann mich gut erinnern ich saß
damals in frankfurt in der lufthansa
lounge auf einen flug nach usa und ich
sah das und ich dachte was ist das denn
man der ton war leise ich hörte ich gar
nicht was sie sagte aber aber ich sah
die die die ausdrucksform von einem
feind eines einer jahr einer dieser drei
mal geredet hat und ich dachte wenn das
die menschen in der welt sehen dann
werden sie mich fragen habt ihr denn in
deutschland echt nichts gelernt und das
ist eigentlich das was ich adressiert
hat dass man mit solchen ausgrenzenden
auftritten dem ansehen deutschlands in
der welt schadet aber sie haben dafür
auch einstecken müssen nämlich mord rom
sich und wie sind sie wie also nun weiß
ich aus eigener erfahrung man denkt die
familie natürlich auch immer mit wenn
man so etwas erhält wie sind sie dann
damit wie sind sie damit umgegangen
ja ich habe ja mehrere solcher drohungen
und die die prominenteste war ja von
einem adolf hitlers nsdap tod kommt man
sich wirklich wundern dass eine solche
weise internet adressen überhaupt zu der
sie es die kann man natürlich fälschen
aber wenn das irgendwie filter auftaucht
mit nsdap dann muss man sich wundern
warum das durchläuft aber er hat daneben
geschrieben
das ist eben zeit ist jetzt daran
abzutreten
und man dafür sorgen wird dass ich das
und ich hab dann zurück geschrieben also
ganz offensichtlich gibt es in der hölle
jetzt auch schon die digitalisierung
weil der teufel schaut mir jetzt schon
ein e mail
das kam dann bei verschiedenen
bevölkerungsschichten nicht sehr gut an
aber dazu stehe ich meine das ist
einfach ausgrenzung hass rassismus das
gehört nicht mehr in unsere zeit wir
haben das wirklich in deutschland in
einer weise gemacht dass der schlimmsten
zivilisations brüche der der
menschheitsgeschichte geführt hat und
aber ich muss jetzt einfach schluss sein
und für sie ist ende des jahres
beziehungsweise dann anfang des nächsten
jahres auch na ja nur so halb schluss
sie gehen dann rüber zu siemens energy
wie stellt man sich das dann vor joe
kaeser auch möglicherweise im home
office zu hause in jogginghose vom
computer naja salafisten brustbild gibt
ist die türkin ist ja nicht so schlimm
aber jetzt ernsthaft ich meine ich werde
ja 40 jahre siemens zurückblicken das
unternehmen hat mir in einer weise
gegeben das ist schon wirklich
beachtlich ich bin wirklich stolz darauf
dass siemens sein zu dürfen immer noch
oder ganz besonders ich habe auch viel
gegeben
die familie musste da auch viel
einstecken
das ist nicht so ohne wollen wir werden
sehen wie die zukünftig ergibt ich es
gibt ein schönes sprichwort ich habe das
jetzt dass ich es gelesen so lange die
lage träume größer sind als die
erinnerung ist eigentlich noch ganz gut
mit dabei und das ist auch ein schönes
schlusswort für die erste sendung und es
werden in viele bei ihrem neuen job auch
auf die finger gucken auch freitags vor
future werden noch vieles mit ihnen zu
besprechen
denn sie haben das eine oder andere
versprechen getan in richtung
klimaschutz sie wollen raus aus der
kohle und wie gesagt da guckt die jugend
aber nicht nur die jugend ganz genau hin
was joe kaeser machen werdet ihr
versprechen einhalten aber wir müssen
sie einhalten hier einer realen
das ist ganz ganz wichtig wir würden die
welt anders bauen wenn wir siegen habe
noch mehr bauen würden man das wenn ich
das noch sagen darauf als schlusswort
dass das die krone krise hat etwas gutes
gehabt wenn die welt als hier gelernt
hat dann war das wert diese
schrecklichen entbehrungen und
einschränkungen auch von grundfreiheiten
und grundrechten zu nehmen und wir
werden da alle daran gemessen werden
dass wir eine bessere welt bauen und
auch corona aber es gibt eine zeit nach
kardinal darauf reichlich